Hola buenos días la Unión Europea no
quiere repetir los mismos errores del
pasado como le ocurrió con Rusia en que
dependió excesivamente de su gas y se
aprovechó de sus vulnerabilidades por
ello la comisión europea ha presentado
un plan sobre Cómo reducir estas
dependencias del exterior y aunque no
mencione explícitamente a China si se
ASUME como un claro mensaje al gigante
asiático la comisión europea presenta en
su plan varias acciones concretas para
empezar va a pedir que las empresas
extranjeras que quieran participar o
invertir en infraestructuras o empresas
europeas se va a poder estudiar este
tipo de inversión e incluso la comisión
europea Se reserva el derecho de limitar
esta inversión Como por ejemplo ha
ocurrido en el puerto de Hamburgo en
Alemania o en el Porto de Atenas también
se estudia el control de exportaciones
de materiales Como por ejemplo sistemas
de espionaje o también armas a países
considerados hostiles por parte de
empresas europeas y por último también
se quiere limitar que haya inversiones
de empresas europeas hacia países
extranjeros sobre todo en materias Como
por ejemplo en computación cuántica o en
Inteligencia artificial esto es
especialmente importante porque Bruselas
lo que teme Es que la propiedad
intelectual y también y también la
tecnología europea vaya a parar en manos
de China todo esto se va a hablar en una
cumbre de jefes de estado y de gobierno
la semana que viene Aquí en bru